[Musik]
das familienfoto des mega gipfels von
brüssel aus nato eu und g 7 alle sind
drauf der us präsident joe biden
frankreichs präsident emanuel makro
briten premier boris johnson und
natürlich auch olaf
olaf scholz der deutsche bundeskanzler
der fehlt auf diesem foto hier ja grund
dafür so unsere korrespondentin nadja
aswad von vor ort ist ganz
offensichtlich das lange ringen in
berlin zum geplanten maßnahmen paket
entlastungspaket der ampel regierungen
da muss es hoch hergegangen sein dass
olaf schulze sind kaufen und bei dem
wichtigen eröffnungs fototermin in
brüssel abwesend zu sein wenn auf dem
foto steht ganz europa und die usa
zusammen gegen russland und deutschland
fehlt nun eben auf diesen historischen
foto in brüssel ist unsere
korrespondentin nadja aswad für uns
heute den ganzen tag vor dem
nato-hauptquartier all überall dort wo
man sich halt trifft nadja die
wichtigste frage zuerst wo ist dein olaf
scholz wann kommt er denn
jetzt stand den nadja uns nicht
verstehen zu koennen wir werden das aber
nochmal wir können dich sehr gut hören
hat ja kannst du uns jetzt auch hören
wir machen mal testes test
hat ja kann uns offensichtlich nicht
hören in diesem moment dann werden wir
das nachher wenn wir das nachher
weitermachen zugeschaltet sein wird bei
diesem gipfel aus nato eu und g 7 auch
der ukrainische präsident seelen ski
anderen der uns in den vergangenen vier
wochen jeden tag
videobotschaften zugeschickt hat und
auch heute wird er sicherlich der
führung der freien welt die dort
versammelt ist wieder einiges
abverlangen anforderungen wir schauen
uns an
einen stoppelbart die augen liegen tief
in den höhlen tarnfarben statt feinem
anzug ein bild wie es momentan täglich
über die bildschirme der welt flackert
ukraine staatspräsident worden
[Musik]
steigenden energiepreisen das ist
zweifelsohne an gegenwehr
des schrecklichen kriegs in der ukraine
die koalition ist der überzeugung dass
wir die menschen und die wirtschaft
angesichts dieser enormen
preissteigerungen
kurzfristig und befristet
schützen müssen
wir haben es uns in dieser nacht nicht
leicht gemacht ein paket zu schnüren das
hat auch etwas zeit gebraucht die
unterschiedlichen maßnahmen zu bewerten
und dann zu einem paket zu verbinden
aber es ist gelungen
innerhalb von vier wochen haben wir ein
erstes entlastungs paket geschnürt ein
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr auf
den weg gebracht und jetzt ein zweites
entlastungspaket und modernisierungs
paket miteinander verabredet innerhalb
von vier wochen hat diese koalition in
krisenhaften zeiten damit ihre
handlungsfähigkeit
gezeigt und hat es vermocht aus
unterschiedlichen perspektiven
dann auch eine gemeinsame position zu
finden
das soll den menschen in diesem land
auch das vertrauen geben dass wir in
dieser krise handlungsfähig sind und
unser land auch vor den negativen
auswirkungen des krieges nach kräften
schützen wir haben ein paket geschnürt
meine damen und herren das maßnahmen der
energie
diversifikation der energie
effizienz und
auch der entlastung der bürgerinnen und
bürger verbindet wir setzen dabei auf
den öpnv auf den technologischen
fortschritt und auf unterschiedliche
steuerliche maßnahmen vor lang und er
klingbeil werden noch auf einzelne
maßnahmen eingehen ich will gerne zwei
nennen für unsere seite
erstens wird es einen
steuerlichen
sonderzuschlag geben für alle
steuerpflichtigen
in höhe von 300 euro eine energie
pauschale eine steuerliche energie
pauschale und zum zweiten wollen wir die
menschen die auf das auto angewiesen
sind pendlerinnen und pendler familien
und gewerbetreibende mit den steigenden
spritpreisen nicht im stich lassen
deshalb haben wir eine maßnahme
beschlossen wir werden den
spritpreis reduzieren beim benzin um 30
cent pro liter und beim diesel um 14
cent pro liter wir gehen damit auf das
minimum der europäischen energie
besteuerung zurück als eine unmittelbare
und für drei monate befristete maßnahme
wir wollen das verbinden auch mit der
stärkung der
markttransparenzstelle des kartellamts
die dafür sorge tragen soll dass diese
entlastung auch wirklich bei den
menschen ankommt
ja auch von mir einen guten morgen
wie erleben harte zeiten sehr viele
menschen auch hier in deutschland spüren
die auswirkungen von steigenden preis
nur wenn es am super einer
supermarktkasse teurer wird wenn die
heizkosten explodieren und wenn der
preis an der spritze eule dann zahlen
soll nach oben geht dann belastet dass
sehr viele menschen unserem land und
deshalb freue ich auch mich sehr dass
wir es geschafft haben in einer
vielleicht etwas längeren sitzung als
wir uns in dieser koalition vorgenommen
haben aber ein umfassendes ein breites
und ein weitreichendes entlastungs paket
auf den weg zu bringen wir müssen
handeln und deshalb handeln wir als
ampel und wir haben dabei die breite der
gesellschaft im blick ich glaube wir
müssen aber auch ehrlich sein und zu
ehrlichkeit gehört dazu zu sagen dass
wir nicht wissen in diesen schwierigen
zeiten was alles noch auf uns zukommt
und dass wir wahrscheinlich nicht jede
belastungen auffangen können werden dass
wir nicht jede belastung kompensieren
werden können und deshalb ist es umso
wichtiger dass wir in diese situation
eben nicht nur auf das hier und jetzt
schauen dass wir gleichzeitig auch
darauf schauen wie wir solche
situationen in zukunft vermeiden können
also wie wir unabhängiger werden von
russland von russischen gas von
russischem öl und von den fossilen
insgesamt das heißt ja es geht bei
diesem paket ganz konkret um soziale
entlastungen
es geht aber auch um souveränität um
selbstbestimmung in europa und um
freiheit
und dass wir in die breite gehen das
zeigen wir insbesondere auch bei der
mobilität wir machen etwas für die
menschen die aufs auto angewiesen sind
und die besonders viel fahren müssen
aber wir investieren
gleichzeitig massiv in den öpnv und
sorgen so dafür dass noch viel mehr
menschen diesen nutzen können und nutzen
wollen wir machen bus und bahn fahren so
billig wie es in deutschland
wahrscheinlich noch nie war nach dem
prinzip 94 90 das heißt für 90 tage für
drei monate wird es bundesweit tickets
für 9 euro im monat für alle bürgerinnen
und bürger die das in anspruch nehmen
wollen geben damit stärken wir den öpnv
und schaffen eine möglichkeit der
sozialen teilhabe eben auch bei der
mobilität
und wenn wir die letzten tage und wochen
anschauen dann ziehen wir immer wieder
ich habe es vor vier wochen gesagt als
wir das erste entlastungspaket hier
vorgestellt haben es ist seitdem nicht
weniger wahr oder nicht weniger wichtig
geworden dass energiepolitik
sicherheitspolitik ist wenn wir
unabhängig werden wollen von vladimir
putin ein kriegsverbrecher der nicht vor
den schlimmsten völkerrechts verbrechen
zu rückschlägen zurückschreckt dann geht
es jetzt darum die erneuerbaren energien
auszubauen
vor allem geht es aber auch darum auf
effizienz zu setzen wir brauchen
effizienz in allen bereichen und wir
müssen da wo wir so schnell wie möglich
energie einsparen können genau diesen
weg auch ein stein schlagen wir müssen
den einstieg aus dem ausstieg aus dem
gas jetzt angehen und jetzt wagen darf
eine verschiedene maßnahmen auf den weg
gebracht ich werde ein paar einzelnen
nennen wir werden den ab januar 2024
soll es möglichst jede neu eingebaute
heizung in deutschland zu mindestens 65
prozent mit erneuerbaren energien
betrieben werden dafür haben wir als
grüne lange kämpfe sind sehr froh dass
wir uns hier gemeinsam
als koalition auf diese maßnahme einigen
können und soeben beim energie
verbrauchen bei der effizienz
vorankommen wir finanzieren ein
austauschprogramm von gasheizungen hin
zu wärmepumpen und ermöglichen es so
auch allen unabhängig vom geldbeutel
tatsächlich auch auf energieeffizienz
setzen zu können und machen das so auch
zu einer ja zu einem anliegen dass dem
sozial gerecht gestaltet wird und ab
januar 20 23 wird in neubauer der
effizienzhaus standard 55 festgelegt
damit erhöhen wir die anforderungen für
energieeffizientes für klimafreundliches
bauen und bringt so eben auch die wärme
wende auf den weg ich weiß dass das was
ich jetzt den letzten 30 sekunden ihr
gesagt habe alles sehr sehr technisch
klingt aber es geht dabei um nicht
weniger als den abschied von der
fossilen wärme und den abschied von den
fossilen gasheizungen den wir hier als
koalition angehen wir sehen in diesen
zeiten das unabhängigkeit stärke
bedeutet
und genau darum geht es auch mit diesem
paket stärke dass wir unsere bürgerinnen
und bürger stärken unsere wirtschaft
stärken und unsere souveränität in
europa stärken deshalb machen wir zwei
dinge gleichzeitig als soziales
entlastungspaket aber gleichzeitig auch
eine energiepolitische
unabhängigkeitserklärung
nicht
ja auch von mir mein herzliches
willkommen in der tat es war eine lange
nacht es war intensiv wir haben gut
verhandelt und ich bin sehr froh und
dankbar über das ergebnis das wir als
koalition mit dem zweiten
entlastungspaket jetzt zustande gebracht
haben diese regierung ist knapp 100 tage
im amt ich glaube es gab selten ein
start einer regierung der so viel
abverlangt hat in den ersten 100 tagen
und trotzdem wir heute nacht ein
wichtiges zeichen dass wir auch in
zeiten die neu sind in zeiten die
überraschenden den letzten wochen in
zeiten die uns neue sub verlangt dass
wir als regierung in der lage sind
jederzeit handlungsfähig zu bleiben und
das interesse der bürgerinnen und bürger
in den mittelpunkt unserer politik zu
stellen die zeitenwende die wir gerade
erleben geht von vladimir putin aus die
zeitenwende die wir leben verlangt uns
als deutschland vieles ab im außen- und
sicherheitspolitischen bereich aber und
das war der schwerpunkt heute nacht
diese zeitenwende verlangt uns auch
innenpolitisch etwas ab und das ziel
dieser ampel koalition ist es den
sozialen zusammenhalt den zusammenhalt
als gesellschaft die stabilität in
dieser gesellschaft in diesen zeiten in
zeiten der wende auch zu stärken und
dafür haben wir heute ein großes
entlastungs paket auf den weg gebracht
ich will noch einmal erinnern an das
erste entlastungspaket das ja genau vier
wochen her ist 13 milliarden wir haben
dort viele dinge verabredet der
mindestlohn steigt wir haben beschlossen
die eeg-umlage frühzeitig abzuschaffen
wir haben beschlossen die
pendlerpauschale zu erhöhen also 13
milliarden in die hand genommen wurden
um die bürgerinnen und bürger dieses
landes zu entlasten und dafür zu sorgen
dass die stabilität in der zusammenhalt
in diesem land gewährleistet bleiben in
schwierigen zeiten wie es gerade der
fall ist und jetzt haben wir ein zweites
paket auf den weg gebracht einige
maßnahmen wurden gerade schon
angesprochen und wird an den zapfsäulen
jetzt in den nächsten tagen in den
nächsten wochen sehen was wir dort
verabredet haben ricarda lang hat gerade
etwas angesprochen mit dem programm
99 dass wir den öpnv stärken wollen das
auch den anreiz noch mal setzen wollen
dort wo es möglich ist
der kauf den öffentlichen nahverkehr
umzusetzen aber für uns sozialdemokraten
das will ich hier betont ist ein
kernstück dieser verabredung heute nacht
die energiepreis pauschale die wir
verabredet haben in der koalition jeder
erwerbstätige wird 300 euro als
einmalzahlung vom staat bekommen damit
soll abgefedert werden das was gerade an
den zapfsäulen stattfindet damit sollen
steigen heizkosten abgefedert werden
damit soll noch steigende inflation und
lebensmittelkosten abgefedert werden
neben den vielen anderen maßnahmen die
auch schon verabredet wurden gehen der
koalition diese 300 euro für jeden
erwerbstätigen werden dann über die
einkommenssteuer abgerechnet und werden
über die arbeitgeber ausbezahlt
beziehungsweise bei selbständigen denn
über eine geminderte vorauszahlung die
beim finanzamt stattfindet und wir haben
verabredet dass es den familienzuschuss
geben wird das heißt für jedes kind 100
euro noch mal zusätzlich auch hier
werden soziale härten die es gerade gibt
in diesem land zusätzlich abgefedert und
eine weitere maßnahme die für uns
sozialdemokratinnen und sozialdemokraten
aber für die ganze koalition wichtig war
ist dass wir transferleistungsempfänger
nach dem ersten entlastungspaket wo er
schon mal die einmalzahlung von 100 euro
verabredet wurde jetzt mit einer
weiteren einmalzahlung von noch mal 100
euro auch in diesen zeiten unterstützen
werden
ich kann hier noch einmal betonen dass
mein vorredner gesagt haben wir sind mit
unterschiedlichen blickwinkeln auch
perspektiven mit unterschiedlichen
forderungen in diesen
koalitionsausschuss gegangen wir sind
dankbar für das was an vorarbeit durch
die neunergruppe geleistet wurde ich
will hier an dieser stelle nochmal
denjenigen auch danken die von
sozialdemokratischer seite dabei waren
vor allem matthias mierisch aber auch
anke rehlinger die eigentliche im
wahlkampf ist aber sich trotzdem als
stellvertretende parteivorsitzende sehr
intensiv in den letzten tagen zeit
genommen hat und im interesse der
bürgerinnen und bürger auch
verbesserungen auf den weg zu bringen
und wir konnten jetzt die vorarbeit der
neuner gruppe heute nacht finalisieren
es ist etwas auf den weg gebracht worden
das zeigt diese regierung handelt in
schwierigen zeiten diese regierung
stellt das interesse der bürgerinnen und
bürger in den mittelpunkt und diese
regierung ist etwas was
unterschiedlichen blickwinkeln jeweils
das gute zusammengeführt wird im
interesse des landes vielen dank
meine damen und herren das war also die
lang erwartete vorstellung der
entlastungen für die bürger unser land
soll vor negativen auswirkungen des
krise krieges geschützt werden sagte der
fdp vorsitzende
lindner gehen wir mal durch wir haben
notierte sandra was da an entlastungen
kommt ich fange mal an mit christian in
das gerade gesagt es gibt entlastungen
für die bürger und das ist wichtig für
alle die da draußen ein auto haben es
gibt tatsächlich jetzt entlastungen beim
tanken der spritpreis wird es reduziert
und das schon in den nächsten tagen so
christian lindner der dieselpreis der
fällt um 14 cent pro liter und benzin
sogar um 30 cent das ist für drei monate
befristet zusätzlich gibt es eine
energie pauschale also einmalig 300 euro
als sonderzuschlag außerdem soll und das
hat dann die grüne ricarda lang die
grünen-vorsitzende ricaner lang
vorgestellte soll er sie drei monate
bundesweit tickets für 9 euro im monat
im öffentlichen personennahverkehr geben
also 9 für 90 heißt dieses programm 9
euro für jeden monat und dann sagte lars
klingbeil zum schluss noch das auch die
familien profitieren werden für jedes
kind gibt es zusätzlich noch einmal
100-euro
familienzuschuss und ebenso für
empfänger von sozialleistungen auch noch
mal 100 euro
einmalig eine energiepolitische
unabhängigkeitserklärung soll das auch
sein dass afrikaner lang noch gesagt mit
blick auf die zukunft jede neue
heizungen in deutschland musste ab 2024
zu 65 prozent mit nur erneuerbaren
energien betrieben werden und es wird
ein austauschprogramme finanziert sodass
gasheizungen durch wärmepumpen ersetzt
werden können und der effizienz standard
für neu bauen wird neubauten wird ab
nächstem jahr ab januar erhöht sprechen
darüber mit johannes vogel ist
stellvertretender bundesvorsitzender der
fdp also eine regierungspartei die an
diesem maßnahmenpaket mitgearbeitet hat
guten morgen herr vogel hallo guten
morgen herr vogel ist das der große
befreiungsschlag für viele bürger aus
dieser energie krise in der wir uns
gerade befinden
ja ich glaube das ist ein gutes paket
wir sind ja einen dynamischen zeiten und
müssen natürlich sehen wie sich auch die
kommenden wochen und monate entwickeln
aber wir haben eben auch gesehen wie
sich die letzten tage und wochen
entwickelt haben und ganz viele menschen
sind durch die steigenden energiepreise
ja belastet aktuell zum beispiel und
insbesondere akut auch in den letzten
tagen und wochen menschen die zb
beruflich aufs auto angewiesen sind weil
schon der krankenschwester zum
polizeibeamten oder menschen die
gewerblich als selbstständiger als
unternehmer aus auto angewiesen sind und
die wollen wir entlasten und haben uns
jetzt als koalition will ich auf ein
sehr gutes paket auch ein breites glück
austariertes paket verständigt aber es
ist ein gerechtes paket der vogel so
besser verdienen werden genauso
entlastet wie geringverdienende
beispielsweise durch die pauschale
senkung der energie von pauschale die
300 euro die es gibt und auch durch die
senkung des benzinpreises der
benzinpreis der natürlich geringer
verdienende viel härter trifft als gut
verdienende
ja das paket hat ja mehrere elemente ich
halte absolut richtig dass es ein
element gibt und das war uns bei
demokraten auch besonders wichtig dass
diejenigen entlastet die durch die
gestiegenen energie- gipfel entschieden
benzinpreise jetzt ganz akut auch durch
putins angriff auf die ukraine belastet
sind und da muss so ein instrument
natürlich auch einen unterschied machen
mit blick auf die frage wer das auto
bell die vielmehr muss es auch wie viel
nutzen und wir sind ja sehen ja in fast
allen europäischen nachbarländern
schweden niederlande belgien italien und
andere was die alle diesen weg gehen aus
gründen der gehen wir jetzt auch wir
haben darüber hinaus ein
instrument mit der neuen pauschale die
eingeführt wird nur für dieses jahr
einer steuerlichen sondern entlasten für
die breite mitte der gesellschaft aber
genauso gut ganz gezielt was für
diejenigen die kleineren einkommen haben
der heizkostenzuschuss der bereits
beschlossen wurde wird von der zuschuss
für diejenigen je der grundsicherung
sind der bereits beschlossen wurde wird
von doppelt also wir haben durchaus
instrumente die auch auf diese gerade
ausgewogenheit achten aber wir haben
noch instrumente die entlasten sollen
die belasten und das ist durchaus auch
die breite mitte der gesellschaft das
halte ich auch für richtig bus und
bahnfahren wird so günstig wie fast noch
nie hier bei uns in deutschland neun
euro pro monat das ganze gilt allerdings
nur für drei monate der krieg der dauert
jetzt schon ein monat und man weiß auch
nicht wie lange er noch geht könnte man
denn da auch noch mal nachlegen wenn
diese drei monate dann beendet sind
ja jetzt gerade ein paket beschlossen
was wir für angezeigt und notwendig
halten in der aktuellen herausforderung
und ich habe das einmal bewusst gesagt
natürlich leben wir in dynamischen
zeiten und niemand kann irgendwas für
die zukunft ausschließen wenn wir gerade
bewiesen dass er aber in der lage und
will den darauf zu reagieren jetzt akut
glaube ich sind das die richtigen
maßnahmen und natürlich ist es wichtig
dass wir auch nicht vom wechsel
dauerhaften politik und wissen reaktion
ich glaube es klug
krisenreaktion daneben auch zeitlich zu
befristen und deshalb werden zum
beispiel die senkung der energiesteuern
was ganz konkret diesen benzinpreise
reduzieren wird und die das angebot eben
auch leichter auf den v auf bus bahn
ausweichen können oder vielleicht auch
ausprobieren zu können wie stark man
aufs auto vielleicht im urbanen bereich
sondern noch stärker verzichten kann das
günstiger zu machen das finde ich ein
ausgewogenes paket aber beides ist eben
eine temporäre maßnahme in einer ganz
akuten krise und deshalb ist glaube ich
richtig dass erst mal für drei monate
das sie vertreten den mittelstand als
fdp herr vogel bauen wird auf jeden fall
teurer werden wenn er 2023 also schon ab
januar nächsten jahres der effizienz
standard für neubauten erhöht werden
wird
ja ich glaube gleichzeitig müssen wir
aber auch sehen dass es notwendig ist
uns aus dem despoten dilemma zu befreien
und das geht eben nur wenn auch bei der
energieeffizienz und bei der
dekarbonisierung von wärme vom baum
vorankommen müssen das so schritt für
schritt machen und auch nicht
förderprogramme dass die chips kommen
aber die aufgabe ist eben richtig man
muss ja neben guter krisenreaktion auch
wichtig frage stellen wie verhindert man
dass man künftig weiter in solchen lagen
ist gleichzeitig ist mir wichtig dass
dieses paket eben gerade auch
selbstständige unternehmer handwerker
gewerbetreibende blick hat diese
steuerliche sondern entlastung die wir
für die mitte der gesellschaft
auf den weg bringen wollen die gruppen
zum beispiel nicht nur auf arbeitnehmer
sondern arbeitnehmer sondern die haben
auch unternehmer und selbständige und
das ist glaube ich genau richtig
vielen dank herr vogel